now i want to use a diode in a circuit
and we'll see how how we uh solve
circuits that include these non-linear
diodes in them so i have a circuit here
with a battery and a resistor and a
diode here and it's going to be a
special kind it's going to be an led
diode so it's going to give off light
this is a kind of diode that's
manufactured to generate photons of
light when it has a current flowing
through it in the forward direction
they're pretty cool and you see them all
the time in electronic components
so we're going to figure out how to use
an led in a real simple little circuit
and in our circuit here we're going to
have a resistor of 330 ohms
and we'll make this
battery three volts
so it's like two double a cells
and what we want to find out is how much
current is going to flow around this
circuit and let me label this here
let me let me label the voltages across
our components we'll have vd
which is this voltage here
and we'll have vr
which is the resistor voltage and that's
that voltage right there
so now i'm going to show you a plot of
the iv curve of our diode you can see
right here around 0.7 volts the the
current rises rapidly when there's 0.7
volts across the diode
and let's start out by analyzing this
let's start with the same tools that we
always have
which is let's try to write some current
laws for these two things
so for the diode we write a current law
that looks like this
the current is equal to is
times
e to the q
v on kt
minus one
so that's the iv characteristic for the
diode where this is
v diode
right there
and the corresponding equation for the
resistor is i equals
v resistor
over
330
ohms
that's just ohm's law for the resistor
and i in both cases is is this i right
here
now if i wanted to i could i could set
these two expressions equal to each
other and solve somehow for vd and vr
but what we're going to do instead is
we're going to solve this by graphing by
a graphical method
here's a graph of the diode
and this is the vd scale this is v diode
and this is i up here
and so what i want to do is i want to
plot the resistor curve on here as well
i want to plot the resistor iv curve on
this same plot
now in this expression i have vr instead
of vd so let me see if i can i can work
on vr here
let me try to figure out vr in terms of
vd
so i can derive vr
as 3 volts
minus vd
and let's put this into this i
expression here the ohm's law expression
now becomes
i equals
v r is replaced with
three minus vd
all over
330
ohms
and let's work on this a little more
i
equals
3 over 330
minus
vd
vd over 330
and this is starting to look like the
equation of a line
let me write this to recognize it as an
equation of a line
minus
vd
over 330
plus
333
over 330 is
9 milliamps
so this is the equation of a line and
the slope is right here is minus 1 over
330
and the i intercept is 9 milliamps
so let's see if we can plot this line
this is actually called a
load line
that's just a nickname for this kind of
expression that you get when you have a
resistor when you have a resistor
connected to a fixed power supply above
and the resistor's hanging down from it
you get this characteristic equation of
a line that has a negative slope which
is really distinctive
let's see if we can plot this line now
it's a line so all we have to do is find
two points that solve the line and then
we'll be able to draw the line
so if i set vd equal to zero then i
equals
nine milliamps so
here's vd equal to zero
and it'll go through nine milliamps so
that's
one point on the line
but what else can i set to zero i can
set i equal to zero which means i'm on
the voltage axis
and what i'm actually going to do is i'm
just going to look at my circuit and
figure this out in my head
so i'm setting i equal to 0
and i equals 0 means there's no current
in this resistor which means there's no
voltage drop across that resistor and
that means that this voltage here
is the same as this voltage here
and i know the voltage here the voltage
here is 3 volts
so that means the voltage here is 3
volts
and that's because i know the current is
zero
so let's go over and put that point on
our line so when i is zero
v is three volts so there's another
point on the line
and now we have two points and we can
draw a line between them
like that
and what we've drawn is the load line
for this 330 ohm resistor
you remember back over here we said we
could solve these two equations by
setting the two i's equal to each other
and that's basically where do these two
lines intersect and they intersect
right here
that's the solution to our
to our problem
so this intersection point is the
solution it's where the resistor current
and the diode current are the same
and that's that point there and now i
can just read off my answer
right there is about
0.7 volts
and the current over here
if i read off the current
just straight across there it's about
6.8
milliamps of current
so now we actually just solved our
circuit
using a graphical technique
and what that says is
there let me erase this a bit to clean
it up
let me take out these two things here
that was the that was just the resistor
load line that we were talking about
and now for our solution we have i
equals
6.8 milliamps
and v
v diode equals about 0.7 volts
so that's how you do a graphical
solution with a diode